MAX: This week, we're talking
about Cloud Run, sea cables,
and managing your cloud.
I'm Max, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
First up, a minor update, Cloud
Run is generally available.
Cloud Run is a fully
managed serverless execution
environment that lets you
run stateless containers
without worrying
about infrastructure.
We're pretty obsessed
with it over here,
and we hope you like it, too.
So check out this
little product.
It might just make your day.
Once you've fallen in
love with Cloud Run,
you may find yourself with
multiple cloud solutions.
That's OK.
It turns out, for many
enterprise networks,
it's complicated.
Most businesses end up with
multi-cloud or hybrid cloud
and on-prem deployments.
The Network
Intelligence Center was
designed to simplify things
for your network operations
team by providing
comprehensive visibility
into your entire cloud strategy.
As you scale that cloud
strategy, it's important to us
that you are only ever
charged for what you use,
and that you're using
exactly what you need.
To help, the Budget API has
also been released to beta.
The Budget API is designed
for managing budgets
programmatically at
scale, which is critical
when you have multiple budgets
across an organization.
Try it out, and let us
know what you think.
Subsea cables are literally
changing the world
by using a data pipe to bring
continents closer together,
metaphorically
speaking, of course.
The Curie cable is
10,500 kilometers long
and runs from the US to Chile.
And now that it's
operational, we're
starting on the first
branch to Panama.
No matter where your
users are, Google Cloud
is here to help you reach them.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas,
leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.